hello everyone
welcome to this tutorial by simply learn
in this video
you will learn about an interesting
machine learning topic that is
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement learning
let's discuss each of them in detail and
understand when to use these algorithms
along with their applications now there
are a number of
algorithms used in the field of machine
learning to solve complex problems
each of these algorithms can be
classified into a certain category
so the different types of machine
learning algorithms are supervised
learning
unsupervised learning and reinforcement
learning
now let's look at the definition of each
of these learning techniques
supervised learning uses labeled data to
train machine learning models
labeled data means that the output is
already known to you
the model just needs to map the inputs
to the outputs
an example of supervised learning can be
to train a machine that identifies the
image of an animal
below you can see we have a trained
model that identifies the picture of a
cat
unsupervised learning uses unlabeled
data to train machines
unlabeled data means there is no fixed
output variable
the model learns from the data discovers
patterns and features in the data and
returns the output
here is an example of an unsupervised
learning technique that uses the images
of vehicles to classify if it's a bus or
a truck
so the model learns by identifying the
parts of a vehicle
such as the length and width of the
vehicle the front and rear end covers
roof hoods the types of wheels used etc
based on these features the model
classifies if the vehicle is a bus or a
truck
reinforcement learning drains a machine
to take suitable accents and maximize
reward in a particular situation it uses
an agent and an environment to produce
actions and rewards
the agent has a start and an end state
but there might be different parts
for reaching the end state like a maze
in this learning technique
there is no predefined target variable
an example of reinforcement learning is
to train a machine
that can identify the shape of an object
given a list of different objects such
as
square triangle rectangle or a circle
in the example shown the model tries to
predict the shape of the object
which is a square here now
let's look at the different machine
learning algorithms that come under
these learning techniques
some of the commonly used supervised
learning algorithms are linear
regression
logistic regression support vector
machines k nearest neighbors
decision tree random forest and naive
bayes
examples of unsupervised learning
algorithms are k-means clustering
hierarchical clustering db scan
principle component analysis and others
choosing the right algorithm depends on
the type of problem you are trying to
solve
some of the important reinforcement
learning algorithms are q learning
monte carlo sarsa and deepq network
now let's look at the approach in which
these machine learning techniques work
so supervised learning takes labeled
inputs and maps it to known outputs
which means you already know the target
variable unsupervised learning finds
patterns and understands the trends in
the data to discover the output
so the model tries to label the data
based on the features of the input data
while reinforcement learning follows
trial and error method to get the
desired solution
after accomplishing a task the agent
receives an award
an example could be to train a dog to
catch the ball
if the dog learns to catch a ball you
give it a reward such as a biscuit
now let's discuss the training process
for each of these learning methods
so supervised learning methods need
external supervision to train machine
learning models
and hence the name supervised they need
guidance and additional information to
return the result
unsupervised learning techniques do not
need any supervision to train models
they learn on their own and predict the
output similarly
reinforcement learning methods do not
need any supervision to train machine
learning models
and with that let's focus on the types
of problems that can be solved using
these three types of machine learning
techniques so supervised learning is
generally used for classification and
regression problems we'll see the
examples in the next slide
and unsupervised learning is used for
clustering and association problems
while reinforcement learning is reward
based so for every task
or for every step completed there will
be a reward received by the agent
and if the task is not achieved
correctly there will be some penalty
used now
let's look at a few applications of
supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement learning
as we saw earlier supervised learning
are used to solve classification and
regression problems
for example you can predict the weather
for a particular day based on humidity
precipitation wind speed and pressure
values
you can use supervised learning
algorithms to forecast sales for the
next month or the next quarter for
different products
similarly you can use it for stock price
analysis or identifying if a cancer cell
is malignant or benign
now talking about the applications of
unsupervised learning
we have customer segmentation so based
on customer behavior
likes dislikes and interests you can
segment and cluster similar customers
into a group
another example where unsupervised
learning algorithms are used is
customer churn analysis now
let's see what applications we have in
reinforcement learning
so reinforcement learning algorithms are
widely used in the gaming industries to
build
games it is also used to train robots to
perform human tasks
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on supervised versus
unsupervised versus reinforcement
learning
i hope you liked this video if you
enjoyed watching this video then please
subscribe to the simple one channel and
hit the bell icon to never miss an
update
thank you for watching and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here